Я не розумію як можна зажимати
фінансування на потреби мешканців
Херсонської області Я розумію що
Більшість депутатів там в житті не були
і туди приїжджати і не збираються але
там кожен день обстріли там кожен день
загиблі там кожен день руйнування там
кожен день потреби по ремонтах зрештою
там кожен день потреба
військовослужбовців і там критично
потрібний додатковий ресурс щоби
забезпечувати і випікання хліба і
медицину і захист цивільного населення
від тих бомбардувань які постійно там
відбувається і у нас є кошти на бюро
економічної безпеки у нас є кошти на
Мінфін і Мінюст А на Херсонську область
у нас коштів немає Ну доголосувалися ви
вже тут всі до
ручки